21 year old jaswen Singh child is the
first person to admit treason in over 40
years
this is the crossbow he was carrying
when caught ready to fire it was loaded
with the bolt and the safety catch was
off
it was Christmas morning in 2021 when he
was spotted in the grounds of Windsor
Castle using a nylon rope ladder he'd
scaled a wall and was in line of sight
of the Queen's private apartment she was
at home celebrating Christmas with her
family it's thought child had been in
the grounds here for two hours before he
was approached by a royal Protection
Officer as he was arrested he told them
twice I am here to kill the queen
he was wearing this mask which officers
said made him look like something out of
a vigilante movie or dressed for
Halloween the head of the Met police
counted terrorism command said this was
an extremely serious incident but one
which the patrolling officers who
apprehended chyle managed with great
composure and professionalism
prosecutors say child was avenging a
massacre in India in 1919 appearing via
video he pleaded guilty to three charges
including one under the treason act
the last person convicted of treason was
Marcus Sergeant who fired blanks at the
queen during trooping the color in 1981.
jaswan Singh child will be sentenced at
the end of March Laura bundock Sky News
Windsor